need action we have the ability as a
country and the government have the
ability as our government to recognize
palestine today we don't have to wait so
let's just act and not wait
[Applause]
the question is as on the order paper as
many of that opinion say i
of the country no
i think the eyes have it the eyes have
it
before we come to the prime minister's
statement on the ukraine i would like to
point out that the british sign language
interpretation proceedings is available
to watch on parliament live tv i now
call the prime minister to make a
statement prime minister johnson
thank you mr speaker i've just come from
a meeting of g7 leaders joined by
secretary general stoltenberg of nato
and with permission i'll update the
house on our response to president
putin's onslaught against a free and
sovereign european nation
shortly after four o'clock this morning
i spoke to president zielenski of
ukraine as the first missiles struck his
beautiful and innocent country and its
brave people and i assured him of the
unwavering support
of the united kingdom
and i can tell the house
that at this stage
ukrainians are offering a fierce defense
of their families and their country
and i know that every honourable member
will share my admiration for their
resolve
earlier today
president putin delivered another
televised address and offered the absurd
pretext that he sought the
demilitarization and
denatification of ukraine
in fact he is hurling the might of his
military machine against a free and
peaceful neighbor in breach of his own
explicit pledge and every principle of
civilized behavior between states
spurning the best efforts of this
country and our allies to avoid
bloodshed
for this putin
will stand condemned in the eyes of the
world and of history
he will never be able to cleanse the
blood of ukraine from his hands
and although the uk and our allies tried
every avenue for diplomacy until the
final hour i'm driven to conclude that
putin was always determined to attack
his neighbor no matter what we did
now we see him
for what he is
a blood-stained aggressor
who believes
in imperial conquest
i am proud that britain did everything
within our power to help ukraine prepare
for this onslaught and we will do our
utmost offer more help as our brave
friends defend their homeland
our embassy took the precaution on 18th
of february of relocating from kiev to
the city of livid in western ukraine
where our ambassador melinda simmons
continues to work with the ukrainian
authorities and to support british
nationals
now
we have a clear mission
diplomatically
politically
economically
and eventually
military
this hideous and barbarous venture of
vladimir putin must end in failure
at the g7 meeting this afternoon we
agreed to work in unity to maximize the
economic price that putin will pay for
his aggression and this must include
ending europe's collective dependence on
russian oil and gas
that has served to empower putin for too
long so i i welcomed again chancellor
schultz's excellent decision to halt the
certification of north stream too
mr speaker countries that together
comprise about half the world economy
are now engaged in maximizing pressure
economic pressure on one that makes up a
mere two percent for our part today the
uk is announcing the largest and most
severe package of economic sanctions
that russia has ever seen
with new financial measures we're taking
new powers to target russian finance in
addition to the banks we've already
sanctioned this week today in concert
with the united states we are imposing a
full asset freeze on vtb
more broadly these powers will enable us
totally to exclude russian banks from
the uk financial system which is of
course by far the largest in europe
stopping them from accessing sterling
and clearing payments through the uk
and with around half of russia's trade
currently in us dollars and sterling i'm
pleased to tell the house that the
united states is taking similar measures
these powers will also enable us to ban
russian state and private companies from
raising funds in the uk
banning dealing with their securities
and making loans to them
we will limit the amount of money that
russian nationals will be able to
deposit in their uk bank accounts
and sanctions will also be applied to
belarus
for its role in the assault on ukraine
overall we'll we'll be imposing asset
freezes on more than 100 new entities
and individuals on top of the hundreds
that we've already announced
this includes all the major
manufacturers that support putin's war
machine
furthermore
we are also banning
aeroflot from the uk
next on top of these financial measures
and in full concert with the united
states and the eu
we will introduce new trade restrictions
and stringent export controls similar to
those that they in the us are
implementing we will bring forward new
legislation
to ban the export of all dual use items
to russia
including a range of high-end and
critical technological equipment and
components in sectors
including electronics telecommunications
and aerospace
legislation to implement this will be
laid early next week
these trade sanctions will constrain
russia's military industrial and
technological capabilities for years to
come
we're bringing forward measures on
unexplained wealth orders from the
economic crime bill to be introduced
before the house rises for easter and we
will set out further detail before
easter on the range of policies to be
included in the full bill in the next
session including on reforms to
companies house and a register of
overseas property ownership
we will we will set up a new dedicated
kleptocracy cell in the national crime
agency to target sanctions evasion and
corrupt russian assets
hidden in the uk
and that means oligarchs in london will
have nowhere to hide and mr speaker
i know that this house
will have great interest in the
potential of cutting russia out from
swift
and
i can confirm as i've always said
that nothing is off the table
but for all these measures to be
successful
it is vital
that we have the unity of our partners
the unity in the g7 and other forums and
uh mr speaker
russian
investors
are all already delivering their verdict
on the wisdom of putin's actions and so
far today russian stocks are down by as
much as 45
wiping 250 billion dollars from their
value in the biggest one day decline on
record
spare bank russia's biggest lender is
down by as much as 45
and gaz
problem down by as much as 39 while the
ruble has plummeted to record lows
against the dollar
we will continue on a remorseless
mission to squeeze russia from the
global economy piece by piece day by day
and week by week and we will of course
use britain's position
in every international forum
to condemn
the onslaught against ukraine
and we will counter the kremlin's
blizzard of lies and disinformation by
telling the truth about putin's war of
choice and his war of aggression and we
will work with our allies on the urgent
need to protect other european countries
that are not members of nato and who
could become targets of putin's playbook
of subversion and aggression
and we will resist
any creeping temptation
to accept what putin is doing today
as a fate accompli
there can be no creeping normalization
not now not in the month to come not in
the years ahead we must strengthen
nato's defenses still further and so
today i called for a meeting of nato
leaders which will take place tomorrow
and i will be convening the countries
that contribute to the joint
expeditionary force which is led by the
united kingdom and comprises both nato
and non-nato members
last saturday
i warned
that this invasion would have global
economic consequences and
this morning the oil price
has risen strongly
the government will do everything
possible to safeguard our own people
from the repercussions for the cost of
living
and of course we stand ready
to protect our country from any threats
including
in cyberspace
above all the house will realize
the hard and heavy truth
that we now live in a continent where an
expansionist power
deploying one of the world's most
formidable military machines is trying
to redraw the map of europe in blood
and conquer an independent state by
force of arms
and it's vital for the safety of every
nation that putin's squad adventure
should ultimately fail and be seen to
fail
however long it takes that will be the
steadfast and unflinching goal of the
united kingdom
i hope of every member of this house and
every one of our great allies
certain that together we have the power
and the will to defend the cause of
peace and justice as we have always done
and i say to the people of russia again
whose president has just authorized an
onslaught against a fellow slavic people
i cannot believe that this horror is
being done in your name
or that you really want the pariah
status that these actions will bring to
the putin regime
and to our ukrainian friends in this
moment of agony i say that we are with
you and we are on your side your right
to choose your own destiny is a right
that the united kingdom and our allies
will always defend and in that spirit i
join you in saying slava ukraine and i
commend this statement to the house
i now call the leader of the opposition
kirstar
thank you mr speaker
in this dark hour
our thoughts our solidarity and our
resolve
are with the ukrainian people
invading troops marched through their
streets
missiles shelled their cities
they've been cast into a war through no
fault of their own
because putin fears their freedom
and because he knows that no people will
choose to live under his bandit rule
unless forced to do so
at the barrel of a gun
the consequences of putin's war of
aggression
will be horrendous and tragic
for the people of ukraine
but also
for the russian people
who've been plunged into chaos by a
violent elite
who have stolen their wealth
stolen their chance of democracy
and stolen their future
and we must prepare ourselves for
difficulties here
we will face economic pain
as we free europe from dependence on
russian gas and oil
and clean our institutions from money
stolen from the russian people
but the british public have always been
willing to make sacrifice
to defend democracy
on our continent
and we will again
the consequences of putin's actions will
be felt throughout the world for years
and i fear for decades to come
russia's democratic neighbors
and every other democracy that lives in
the shadow of autocratic power are
watching their worst nightmare unfold
so all of us who believe in democracy
over dictatorship
in the rule of law over the reign of
terror
in freedom over the jackboot of tyranny
must unite and take a stand
we must support the ukrainian people in
their fight
and we must ensure
that putin fails
putin will eventually learn the same
lesson that european tyrants earned in
the last century that the resolve of the
world is harder than he imagines
that the people's desire for freedom
burns brighter than he can ever
extinguish
and that the light of liberty will
prevail over his darkness
for that to happen
we must make a clean break with the
failed approach to handling putin
which after georgia after crimea after
donbass has fed his belief
that the benefits of aggression outweigh
the costs
we must finally show him
that he is wrong
that means doing all that we can to help
ukraine defend herself
by providing weapons equipment and
financial assistance
as well as humanitarian support for the
ukrainian people
we must urgently reinforce and reassure
our nato allies in eastern europe who
now stand at the frontier of putin's
aggression
and the hardest possible sanctions must
be taken against the putin regime
it must be isolated
its finances frozen
its ability to function crippled
that means excluding russia from the
financial mechanisms like swift
and banning trade in russian sovereign
debt
i welcome the set of sanctions outlined
by the prime minister just now
and pledge opposition support for
further measures
and there are changes we must make here
in the uk
for too long our country has been a safe
haven
for the money that putin and his fellow
bandits stole from the russian people
it must now change
cracking open the shell companies in
which stolen money is hidden will
require legislation
bring it forward immediately prime
minister and labour will support it
along with the other measures that the
prime minister has just
outlined thank you and we will support
it
mr speaker
this must be a turning point in history
we must look back and say
that this terrible day
was actually when putin doomed himself
and doomed his plan to reassert russian
force as a means of controlling eastern
europe to defeat
we know how putin operates
so we know
how to defeat him
he seeks division
so we must stand united
he hopes for inaction
so we must take a stand
he believes that we are too corrupted to
do the right thing
so we must prove him wrong
i believe we can
and in this dark hour
we can step towards the light thank you
mr speaker
prime minister i want to say how
grateful i am to the right honorable
gentleman for the terms in which he has
just spoken and the robust support that
he is uh offering to the government
and to the western alliance mr speaker
at a at a very very difficult time and i
think the whole house can be turning to
some of the issues that he raised very
briefly i think the whole house can be
proud of the of the role that the uk has
played in uh pioneering military uh
support logistical support uh to the
ukrainians the the way the role that we
played in bringing together a ferocious
package of sanctions uh which we will
now implement and we will bring our
allies together uh mr speaker
to protect nato to show uh that
president putin will get a tougher
western alliance as a result of his
actions not a weaker western alliance
and i think mr speaker that events will
show that the russian president has
profoundly miscalculated uh he believes
that he is doing this for his own
political advantage i believe the exact
opposite will prove to be the case uh
because of the resistance that will be
mounted against what he is doing not
just in ukraine but around the world and
we will support those ukrainians uh mr
speaker we will support them uh
economically diplomatically politically
and yes military as well and i know that
in due time we will succeed
theresa may
thank you mr speaker can i welcome my
right honourable friends statement this
afternoon
this house and this country are united
in our defense of democracy and our
support for the ukrainian people
vladimir putin has initiated war in
mainland europe the response must be
unequivocal and absolutely clear so will
my right honourable friend confirm
that the government is putting in place
every possible economic sanction
so that russia feels absolutely the cold
wind of isolation
and the russian people understand that
vladimir putin has brought their state
to a pariah state
prime minister uh
i thank my ronald friend and she's
absolutely right about what the
government is uh setting out to do and i
do indeed believe that that will be the
result for putin and his cronies
we now come to the smp later
mr speaker let me
thank the prime minister for advanced
copy of the statement and let me also
welcome the very close contact he has
kept with the ukrainian president of
course importantly overnight
i was grateful that i had the chance to
meet this afternoon with the
ukrainian ambassador to the uk and
indeed with ukrainian mps
our thoughts and our support is very
much with each and every one of them as
it is with all of the people of ukraine
mr speaker although last night's events
have been prophesied and predicted for
some time
the acts of russian violence aggression
and tyranny
are no less shocking
what we are witnessing is a full-scale
invasion it is an act of war
this is first and foremost an unprovoked
attack on the peace and the innocence of
ukraine and of its people
but it's equally an attack on
international law an attack on our
european democracy an attack on the
peace that our continent has so
carefully built
over the last 75 years
president putin
and president putin alone bears
responsibility
for these horrific acts
and it is he
and his kremlin cabal
who must pay a massive price
for their actions
it is important to say to the russian
people
that we know
that putin is not acting in their name
he is a dictator
he is an imperialist
he is a tyrant
he is much a threat to his own people
as he is to all of us
mr speaker
this is a moment for unity
and it's especially a moment for
european unity
all of the economic sanctions that are
now finally being implemented have one
clear objective
the complete
economic isolation of the russian state
can the prime minister confirm that this
is the objective and that he has agreed
that with his international allies
that economic isolation
must include sanctions on putin and his
network of oligarchs and agents that
expulsion from countries around the
world sanctions on his banks and their
ability to borrow and function and
sanctions on his energy and mineral
companies
and as i said yesterday it must
finally mean cleaning up the sewer of
dirty russian money that has been
running through the city of london for
years
and i know all the complications
involved but can i ask the prime
minister that the actions to be taken to
suspend russia from the swift payment
system one of the steps that would hit
the putin regime the hardest
but just as we
rightly seek to punish putin we must
redouble our support and solidarity for
the ukrainian people
can the prime minister give further
details on the humanitarian aid being
deployed and the plans in place to offer
refuge and sanctuary where necessary to
those that have been displaced
and what plans are in place to evacuate
the families of uk citizens currently in
ukraine given that commercial flights
have now stopped mr speaker
let's not fall for the kremlin
propaganda that they are prepared to
soak up any sanctions
if we act now
if the sanctions are targeted enough
swift enough severe enough if we impose
nothing less than economic isolation
putin and his cronies will suffer the
consequences of their actions
so let us act together
stand together
and most of all
let us stand
with the people of ukraine
mr speaker can i thank again the the
right honourable gentleman for the uh
the wisdom and the statesmanship with
which he has just uh he's just spoken
and uh just on his points in particular
we've put a thousand uh uh
troops on standby to help with
humanitarian exodus in the adjacent
countries uh we have uh people in
forward presence in the adjacent
countries to help uk nationals come out
and he's quite right mr speaker that the
way to uh make these sanctions work as
we discussed today in the g7 uh where
there is a great deal of unity is that
we do them together and we do them at
the same time and that's what we're
doing
can i just say to everybody the prime
minister's got some very important
meetings we'll be running this to 6 30.
those colleagues who don't get him we
are keeping the list like we did from
the other day to try and ensure that
everybody does get a voice in a very
very you'd love to see it don't you
it's a very very important matter i now
come to the chair of the
foreign thank you mr speaker first of
all pay huge tribute to my writer and
friend the prime minister and his
government today for introducing what
sound like the toughest sanctions we've
seen in uh years may i ask him however
to look wider than simply the russian
people and to look at all those who are
enabling putin's economy those who sit
on boards of the businesses that finance
him whether they are former chancellors
of germany or former prime ministers of
france may i ask him to look here close
to home at those who enable who
propagate the propaganda that is being
used by putin to undermine his own
people and free people everywhere and to
update the treason act so that we can
identify them and call them what they
are traitors
can i also ask the prime minister
one last question which is when he
speaks to people around the world that
he speaks with the truth that he can
in russian through the bbc russian
service and starts to broadcast in
languages other than russian into russia
so that all russian peoples can know
their oppression doesn't need to exist
they don't need to side with the tyrant
prime minister
mr speaker i thank him very much and
he's absolutely right that we have to uh
we have to look at the those who have
bet uh the putin regime and there are
there are many many of them and that's
why uh we're looking at all sorts of
ways in which we can address threats uh
to to this state and mr speaker and we
are of course uh making sure that the
messages from this house which is so
which are so impressive in their unity
should should be registered uh by the
people of russia because we mean uh no
ill towards them they are as much in
many ways the victims as the people of
ukraine of this appalling regime and
they need to know what's really going on
damn angela edel
mr speaker um would the
prime minister
um tell us
uh if he can
uh
what's going on with the russian troops
uh going through chernobyl which center
chill through a lot of people's
thoughts when we heard about it yeah
yeah
prime minister i thank the writer i'm
really very much i i hesitate to give
the house a running comment from what
seems a very fluid and very very
dangerous situation but to best my
knowledge she's right in what she says
dr julian thank you mr speaker for the
best part of 50 years britain gave
sanctuary to the governments in exile of
the occupied baltic states
if as appears likely ukraine gets
overwhelmed will we offer to give
sanctuary to a government in exile
pending ukraine's future freedom
prime minister uh of course i thank my
moral friend of course mr speaker we
will give all uh support that we can uh
logistical or otherwise as britain
always has done uh to governments in
exile and at the point i made to
president uh one of the points i
mentioned president zielinski uh this
morning was it it might be necessary for
him to find uh a safe uh place for him
and his uh and his cabinet to go
david speaker with president putin
responsible for this catastrophic human
tragedy the democrats joined all sides
to stand in solidarity with the people
of ukraine i thank the prime minister
for his statement
today must be a wake-up call
the west has been too complacent over
putin's threat for too long we have
taken for granted our fragile alliances
so crucial for the defense of freedom
embolding putin this outrageous act of
aggression
the west cannot be complacent any longer
so will the government reverse its
proposed troop cuts to the british army
and offer far greater military support
to our nato allies in eastern europe and
mr speaker
putin must face the most punitive of
sanctions the world must isolate russia
like the rogue state it is
including the state-backed oil giant
rosneft
20 owned by vp
so will the prime minister commit to
banning
uk investment
in russian oil and gas companies
with immediate effect
mr speaker the uh on his uh point about
investment in
uh in in russian oil and gas as i've
said we must move away uh from all our
dependencies on russian oil and gas and
that is the objective of the uk
government well we're lucky in this
country that we have only three percent
of our gas uh that comes from russia
other european countries are in a much
more exposed uh position on his point
about supporting uh eastern europeans uh
we have as he knows double the size of
our commitment to estonia we've gone uh
bigger in in poland another 350 marines
from four five uh commando uh we're in
the skies above uh romania there's i
don't believe there's another country in
nato that is currently doing more to
strengthen uh nato's eastern defenses
thank you mr speaker my constituency
kensington has strong historical
connections with ukraine so i welcome
this robust approach
my constituency also has seen
significant property investments by
russian investors can i urge my right
honorable friend to accelerate the
introduction of a register of beneficial
ownership of property
yes she's completely right and we need
to unpeel the facade of these companies
these shell companies so we can see who
owns the property concern
hillary ben
thank you very much indeed mr speaker
it's because john stuart mill was right
when he warned
that bad men
need nothing more to compass their ends
than that good men should look on and do
nothing that the whole house will
support the measures that the prime
minister has just announced now in his
statement he said our mission is clear
diplomatically politically economically
and eventually
militarily
what did he mean by using the word
militarily was he referring to providing
further defensive weapons to enable
ukraine to defend himself
yes misters i obviously don't want to go
into uh detail because the uh it is a
very sensitive and difficult business
but yes uh mr speaker we have done uh we
continue to do so and i believe i have
the support of the house uh in intending
uh to continue to do
bob sealy very much indeed mr speaker i
thank the prime minister for his words
and his if i understand correctly early
commitment to an economic crime bill and
a kleptocracy sell in relation to that
will there be a foreign lobbying bill
will there be amendments to libel and
data protection act to stop unscrupulous
law firms offering intimidation services
to oligarchs and kleptocrats
and will the nca be properly funded as
the ifc report suggested so it will be
able to take on the kleptocrats the
autocrats and the oligarchs in this
country
all right mr speaker i'm grateful as i
said in my uh opening statement uh we
are setting up a uh a new uh combating
kleptocracy cell in the national uh
crime agency to target the very uh
individuals that he uh that he mentions
sarah thank you mr speaker let us be
under no illusion we are on the brink of
a potentially enormous humanitarian
crisis which could see massive loss of
life and widespread suffering for the
ukrainian people and all to suffer the
warp bizarre complex of the russian
president the attack on ukraine is also
likely to cause mass displacement of
people potentially triggering a
significant refugee crisis in europe so
can the prime minister tell us what he
is doing to support the ukrainian people
who stay and those who choose to flee
she makes a very important point and i'm
grateful mr speaker because the
humanitarian impact threatens to be
enormous and uh that's why i i've said
what i've said uh about supporting uh
those refugees as they as they come out
of of ukraine uh but we've got to make
sure that we do everything we can to
stabilize uh the ukrainian economy uh to
support uh the government and the uh as
far as we possibly can and that's why
yesterday uh on tuesday i should say i
announced uh the 500 million uh dollar
extra package of development date on top
of the 100 billion pounds we've already
given other countries uh our friends and
allies are working with us to do much
more
sure
does the prime minister agree that the
international order as envisaged in the
atlantic charter of 1941 has been the
most successful in the history of
freedom and democracy and as one of the
architects of that order we have a
special responsibility to defend it and
whilst today's sanctions are extremely
welcome it cannot just be economic
measures we need a fundamental review of
our military capability including
revisiting the integrated review whose
assumptions may now be out of date
mr speaker the the the
integrated review begins uh with the
assertion that the most important area
for our national security uh is the euro
atlantic uh area as i i believe i said
to the honourable general opposite uh on
tuesday and that remains fundamental and
that's why uh we've uh we've continued
with the investment uh that we have in
uh in nato whether we're the second
biggest uh founder of nato's uh as as
the honourable gentleman knows anybody's
he's my own brother friend knows but
he's right in what he says about what's
at stake this is about the whole idea of
that wonderful thing that uh
was so inspiring when some of us we were
young
of a europe whole and free that
fantastic revolution that happened in
1989 and 1990 when communism fell and mr
speaker it was a it was a great moment
for humanity and we mustn't allow it to
slip through our fingers
[Music]
thank you mr speaker
i would like to see
the people of norwich uh that we show
our solidarity with the people of
ukraine um the warm words will not
defend uh the ukrainian people i've been
speaking to people who have been uh
liaising with ukrainian trade unions
people who've been fighting
privatization and wage cuts but they say
one thing but they will not run from
their homes they will defend their
families those people need to be able to
defend themselves i support the prime
minister's uh
assertion that we will be providing more
defensive capabilities for that end but
let me say one thing uh prime minister
and mr speaker will you agree prime
minister that we must have an end to
this by a negotiated settlement and not
by an escalation of military needs
mr speaker i think the whole house
uh everybody in the world
would want president putin to have
chosen the path of negotiation
he had that moment
and that's why if you remember we had
that uh discussion in this house on
tuesday about that that perilous moment
which we all discussed he had that
opportunity i'm afraid he's missed it
he's chosen the path of overwhelming
violence and destruction and i'm afraid
that puts us on a very very different
course and we have to accept that
reality david
davies everybody will wholeheartedly
support the prime minister's sanctions
hopefully against all 140 russian
oligarchs that support putin and against
all the major banks the prime minister
also described the russian state as a
pariah state and he's right because they
have broken international criminal law
on a major scale
can we actually implement our view of
the pariah state by ensuring that
everybody involved in that decision if
they leave russia to go abroad face
international criminal sanctions
wherever they go
i thank my right honourable friend and
that is exactly what we can now do
thanks to the measures that this house
has passed they'll handle it
thank you uh mr speaker uh this morning
we walk to the worst possible news
and i make no apology in hoping for a
diplomatic solution however my party and
i condemn the escalating russian
aggression this is a fluid and
developing situation but we are now in
uncharted territory and i can update the
house that whilst there have been calls
in this place
for alexander to cease broadcasting on
russia today negotiations have obviously
been happening in the background and i
can confirm that he has suspended
broadcasting
today
but we must prepare
[Music]
we must prepare for the worst and i
would ask the prime minister what
what strategy is he bringing forward to
increase the capacity of north sea oil
and gas so that we can support ourselves
and eu member states and protect our
people from a further increase in the
cost of living
mr speaker i i must say i disagree uh
profoundly with what he uh has had to
say about uh negotiating now i don't
think that that that option is uh is
open to us we we must do our our best to
support and protect uh the people of uh
of ukraine and uh and working with our
international friends and allies to
constrict uh what vladimir putin can do
and uh on on his point about uh about
russia today uh mr speaker uh i i simply
observe that uh the the former leader of
the scottish nationalist party is a uh
his name sorry i'm so sorry
i'm sorry his leader i i i understand
the the pleas he entered in defense and
mitigation uh they don't seem to cut
much ice with me
it's a great lady
steve krab is
mr speaker um
i strongly welcome the further set of
sanctions announced by the prime
minister this evening and we look
forward to
further steps being taken in the days
ahead and not being held back by perhaps
some of the slower moving
members of the alliance in europe but
does the prime minister agree with me
that if sanctions are really to bite on
putin and his gangster government then
inevitably it will mean cost and
inconvenience to uk economic interests
but that cost and inconvenience is of
will be of nothing compared to what
people of ukraine are going through and
we stand with them this evening yeah
yeah
yes i'm afraid he's my honorable friend
honorable friend is right it will mean
cost it will mean
inconvenience it will mean difficulty
for us in the uk but that will be a
price worth paying mr speaker for
defeating the objectives of vladimir
putin and showing that aggression does
not pay
dave diana johnson
could i just follow up on the question
from the honourable member for the isle
of wight about the combating kleptocracy
cell in the national crime agency and
just see from the prime minister um a
view whether additional powers will be
required for the national crime agency
and additional resources for them to do
their work
i i thank her very much they they will
of course they have uh plenty of
existing statute but the additional
powers
that they will have amongst other things
will be the ability to uh to peel back
the facade of ownership which i think
will be extremely valuable
jonathan dodge
speaker um whilst this terrible
appalling incident is of course directly
the cause of russia
appalling incident
is of course directly the cause of
russia the u.s collectively have not
been attentive to russia in the way that
we should
can my right honourable friend now say
that whatever happened in the past
moving forward we are not going to let
russia fall between our fingers again
mr speaker i think the lesson of 2014
is that the whole of the west failed to
respond in the way that we should and
when a sovereign country
was invaded and part of that country uh
was occupied i'm afraid it was quite
wrong uh that we tried to manage the
situation with the various diplomatic
processes that we did which in the end
produced absolutely nothing except
finally this catastrophic invasion today
we have to a bitter lesson mr speaker
about how to deal with vladimir putin
thank you mr speaker i agree with the
prime minister that it seems like the
curtain
has now come down on that era that began
in 1989 and we've lived in an era of
change since then this now feels like a
change of era
in this new era
the permissive environment that we
created for the kremlin's quartermasters
to live
to invest and to party in london
sometimes with the prime minister
himself
that must now that must now come to an
end
so let me ask
so let me ask the prime minister this
will he undertake to ensure
that every visa issued to a russian dual
national
is now reviewed
and where proximity to president putin
is proven
that citizenship should be stripped away
yes mr speaker we are doing that though
i think it is i just think it is worth
the house uh remembering the point that
i made the other day not every russian
is a bad person
[Applause]
speaker
can i welcome the package of sanctions
the prime minister has set out and
whilst i understand why it's not been
possible to suspend russia from the
swift payment system at this stage can i
ask what work we're doing with our
european allies to offer them
reassurance so that eventually we can
get to a position where they can be
suspended because that is by far and
away the biggest thing that will isolate
the russian economy
my honourable friend is spotter
the biggest thing would be uh to if
everybody stopped taking russian
hydrocarbons but swift uh swift is uh is
extremely important and it's a belgian
companies i'm sure the house uh knows uh
we're raising it we're trying to
make progress with our our friends but
for obvious reasons it has to be done uh
in unison sure
mr speaker
this morning i spoke with their friends
in kiev who were leaving the country
with
their family their children and we've
all seen the scenes from the capital of
cars
trying to get out so i send my
deepest thanks to the embassy team there
who are doing all they can to support
people but can i ask the prime minister
about two areas of support for ukraine
economic support
and continuing support for defensive
capability
will both of those areas of support
intensify
and can he assure the house i see the
foreign secretary uh telling me so but
can he assure the house that the
government will continue the deepest
possible conversations with the
government in ukraine to ensure that no
matter the assault that comes to from
vladimir putin we will be supporting
them in a deeply meaningful sense
yes on the on on that last point the
answer is certainly yes mr speaker and
you know just for instance uh uh the
other day i was looking at two british
mine sweepers being refitted in a
recyclers i'm sure he uh he knows which
are due to go to to ukraine the question
will be access mr speaker that's what it
all uh depends on it's robert
mr speaker it's crystal clear from this
act of naked aggression that putin
doesn't seek finlandization on his
borders he seeks at best to recreate a
belarus in the south or at worst to
dismember the sovereign state of ukraine
does my right honourable friend agree
with me that that does mean that we need
to build upon the outcome of our
integrated defense review we do need to
think differently about eastern europe
from the past and then at home with his
announcement on bringing forward
economic crime measures it seems that
there is a consensus in this house that
could allow us to bring forward
emergency legislation to bring those
important measures to really hit those
people hard and hit them now
because i i think that that is clearly
the will of the house and it is the will
of the government and that's why i will
be uh taking those important measures
bringing them forward on monday
mr speaker my thoughts are with the
ukrainian people at this time and while
i welcome the sanctions the prime
minister's announced today can he update
the house on whether he plans to
sanction the major state-owned russian
banks such as cerber bank and gaspron
bank and the non-state bank alpha bank
thank you
yes mr speaker
thank you mr speaker the ukrainian powu
chapel at lockhaven my constituency is a
focal point for the ukrainian diaspora
in scotland and prayers are being said
there for their fellow countrymen but
what ukrainians in the uk have
identified being grateful for the
military support that has already been
forthcoming is that there is an
immediate need for medical battlefield
supplies for warm clothing for troops
and for camouflage gear and can my right
honourable friend the prime minister uh
assure the house that they will be
forthcoming
uh i i thank my rather wrong friend very
much he's he raises very important issue
and uh we are we are working on exactly
those uh supplies right now
i thank the prime minister for his
statement and very much welcome the
sanctions that is announced today but
can you give an assurance that the
sanctions are going to target
individuals will also uh
target uh relatives and connected
parties and like the
writing member for swindon
he mentioned the economic crime bill
we've got the
the review of the official secrets act
and the foreign registration
why can't we bring them forward and do
them now they would get huge support
and we've been waiting for some of these
for nearly two years
mr speaker i can i can tell him that we
will certainly be uh making sure that we
uh are able to sanction and do sanction
uh relatives and uh
and other interested parties and
there'll be there'll be a rolling
program
of intensifying sanctions
brisbane have you been one of the
officials that accompanied the then
defense secretaries both moscow and kiev
in 1993 i'm in no doubt that the
signatories of the united states and the
united kingdom on the budapest
memorandum uh gave ukraine the
confidence to give up its nuclear
deterrent
um will my right honourable friend uh
support the united states whatever
extent it is prepared to go
um to stand alongside the united states
in giving whatever military support is
prepared to do so to ukraine
my right honourable friend is absolutely
right to remind the house of the 1994
budapest memorandum which uh
had exactly that effect and created
exactly that obligation on us as one of
the signatories
versions
on these sanctions although does he
share with me the worry that the record
of driving out dictators and demagogues
is shared with the sanctions isn't
always that successful
does he share my concern
that if you've if we've read what putin
has been saying these last few hours
he is a man that might not stop at
ukraine he might go into a nato country
and i'll are we playing that scenario
because many of us think that might be
the next step
the rather normal gentleman is
absolutely right to raise that appalling
possibility
and it is vital that we reaffirm again
that under article 5 of the nato treaty
we stand four square behind every one of
our nato allies and and uh will come to
their defense ian duncan
speaker can i say to my radical friend
that with ukrainian men and women
dying to fight against the russians for
their freedom today those who are
calling for negotiation at this point
can only please that rambling wreck of a
neo-nazi sitting in the kremlin and they
should be shunned
secondly can i just say to my honourable
friend today the ambassador
from ukraine
asked desperately whether
nato would look at a no-fly zone i know
it's a difficult choice because my
roundabout friend stepped to the
dispatch box and make it clear that in
this particular case
he rules nothing out
mr speaker i i know that uh my right
honourable friend is a is a great
military expert and i he and he will
understand and i understand the
attractions of the of of the note 5 zen
i remember uh the no-fly zone that was
created in uh 1991 as i recall in uh in
northern iraq uh the situation here is
very is very different uh we would face
the risk of having to shoot down uh
russian planes mr speaker uh and that is
something that i think the uh the house
would want to uh to contemplate uh with
caution
russell
speaker in locking out russian state
money i hope the prime minister can give
me a reassurance that that will include
our overseas territories and
dependencies that must be included in
this and i note that there are mr
speaker protest in a number of russian
cities across russia at the moment and
celebrities in russia have been speaking
out i do hope that we will be offering
all the support that we can to those
people who are likely to be shunned by
the fascist imperialist putin regime
yes and uh and can i say mr speaker that
one of the reasons why i want to keep
our fantastic british embassy staff
in moscow even though the temptation is
there simply to sunder diplomatic
relations with putin i want to keep them
there to support groups such as the uh
the ones he mentions
bob stewart
mr speaker i've given
evidence for war crimes trials
it was uh genocide
and crimes against humanity the people
were charged with
could i ask my right honourable friend
and the house
to agree with me that any russian
who kills a ukrainian must remember
that one day they may well be brought to
court
for crimes against humanity or genocide
yes mr speaker and not just any russian
competent uh mr speaker but anyone who
sends a russian uh
into battle uh to kill innocent
ukrainians
thank you mr speaker president zielenski
has called for the toughest possible
sanctions for them to be the toughest
possible that must mean immediate
so in his statement
he talked about in the next session for
the economic
measures
including on company's house and on
the register of overseas property
ownership but in answer to the right
honourable member for swindon he said
something about bringing forward on
monday which of these is it and if it is
monday will it have the same effect as
is required for that immediate action
we'll be bringing it forward on monday
mr speaker and we want to have uh and we
want i hope that i i'm grateful for the
support of the opposition and we want
immediately to start cracking down on
these individuals
jesse norman uh thank you mr speaker the
whole house will welcome the enhanced
package of sanctions that the prime
minister has announced today but can i
raise the question of football much
beloved to russian hearts and in
particular issues of ownership of
property and of shareholdings and of the
future participation of russian clubs in
international
matches he's right uh my my right on
friend is completely right uh the
russians attach a great deal of
sentimental importance to uh to football
and uh they they they hope to have the
the uefa championship uh final in uh in
some petersburg i cannot for the life of
me uh see how that can currently go
ahead liz seville roberts
putin's war on ukraine is brutal illegal
and a calculated attack on peace and
stability in europe applied can we fully
supports the actions and sanctions
announced today houston his cronies and
their personal fortunes must pay for
their actions
on a visit to ukraine plaguing leaders
spoke to ukrainian soldiers government
officials and organizations admiring
ukrainian people for their strength and
their resilience and they are now in
harm's way
with poland organizing medical
assistance and slovakia opening its
borders to refugees will his government
mobilize and resource a global effort to
support and aid people fleeing this
horrific conflict
again mr speaker i thank her very much
for her uh her support and her her
resolve and uh i i want to assure her
that we're of course working with our
international friends uh to to uh
prepare for a humanitarian crisis
speaker earlier this afternoon i had the
opportunity to speak to on a zoom call
with a number of ukrainian mps who were
all calling for additional support one
of the key things they were discussing
is concerns that their communications
networks may get shut down so can i urge
a prime minister to ensure doing all we
can to provide things like satellite
phones to make sure they can communicate
not just internally but with us here in
the uk too
mr speaker
she's absolutely honorable my older
friend is absolutely right uh there is a
threat to communications already and
we're observing it in the uh the
contacts that we're having with uh with
people in in ukraine satellite phones uh
certainly are an option and we'll be uh
we'll be looking at that
sarah owen
thank you mr speaker we've rightly heard
a lot about tougher trade sanctions
today but nothing about ridding russian
state influence from our democracy will
the prime minister commit to
investigating all political donations
received from people with links to putin
and will his government finally bring
forward measures to clean up the corrupt
russian money that for far too long has
been launched in the uk yeah yeah
so mr speaker all political donations
are properly registered and uh and and
monitored and uh i i and i can tell her
that uh we are
putting forward and progressively over
the last
few days and weeks
and today uh the biggest ever package to
crack down on dirty russian money uh not
just from russia but from anywhere
speaker i welcome these sanctions today
my right honourable friend's been
crystal clear that all europe needs to
end dependence on russian oil and gas
could he tell us a little bit more about
how he intends to see that that comes to
pass
the thank you i thank you in fact my
right honourable friend the key thing is
for to get people first of all to
recognize the scale of their dependency
as in any addiction uh and
um that's what we're we're doing and the
uk government's been making that point
the whole time to our friends because
it's got worse since 2014 uh but what
we're also doing is helping countries
prisons in the in the baltic states uh
to go further and faster with renewable
technology
thank you mr speaker i think everyone
knows that the ukraine is a major
producer of grain and unfortunately
because of these awful events there are
likely to be consequences for many
countries including our own could ask
the prime minister to look again at our
food security proposals and make sure
that we are secure ourselves and not
reliant as so much as we have been in
the past
[Music]
yeah he's absolutely right and uh and
food security is an important
consideration and one of the one of the
many things that uh our fantastic
ukrainian community have have done in
the last few years is is help us in that
very sector
under a bridge
thank you mr speaker does my rightful
friend agree with me that western
europe's ongoing reliance on russian oil
and gas has been a major factor in
involving president putin in the
mistaken belief that he can invade his
peaceful neighbor with relative impunity
and in the uk shouldn't we refocus our
energy policy on maximizing the use of
our own natural resources looking again
at fracking while we invest in low
carbon alternatives
yes the
honourable gentleman is totally right uh
my old friend is totally right when he
uh he talks about the excessive
dependence on on on hydrocarbons we're
moving away from it in this country i do
think in that there is a a merit i think
he and i might be in agreement on this
there is a merit in the in a
transitional phase in continuing uh with
the uh the the use of of hydrocarbons in
this country uh rather than pointlessly
importing them from abroad
putin's imperial bloodlust won't stop at
ukraine we're rightly focused on
sanctions military and humanitarian
support and our commitment to ukrainian
freedom but the prime minister knows
there's been a phenomenal increase in
russian submarine activity over the last
20 years
r and rc cables carry more than 95 of
all western military diplomatic
commercial financial and personal
communications the consequences of these
cables being weaponised is terrifying
can he assure me that covering this
threat is part of our ongoing dialogue
with allies
she's absolutely right and uh that there
is a continual uh struggle going on
beneath the surface of the sea as she
knows uh between uh submarines that are
out to uh to sever uh cables and and and
uh those of us who are trying to make
sure that those links are maintained
so charles walker
mr speaker following on from my right
honourable and gallant friends question
about war crimes i suspect those crimes
are already being committed
by russian soldiers against their slavic
brothers and sisters
can the prime minister join with his
nato heads of state setting out at an
early stage how war crimes will be
prosecuted so all russian soldiers field
officers generals and of course as the
prime minister said politicians are
brutally aware of where where they will
end up in a few years time
yeah yeah very good
he is absolutely right
and that thank him i thank you very much
that's why we're uh we're working on
setting up a particular international uh
war crimes tribunal for those involved
in uh war crimes in the ukraine theater
has been incredibly ruthless president
putin is also incredibly rich with one
assessment saying that his personal
wealth is up to 200 billion dollars so
can the prime minister ensure that
president putin himself
pays
a heavy price by targeting his own cash
and assets
yes
absolutely uh mr speaker and not just
him uh but as the house has heard over
the last few days uh as many of his uh
immediate trainees and family as we can
hear
so batting
mr speaker and i thank the prime
minister for all that he's done uh just
before today but i spoke to some of the
ukrainian protesters who are outside uh
one of them was holding back tears and
she spoke about her mother in a cellar
as a house is surrounded by ukrainian
tanks so any member of this house who's
asking for a negotiated settlement needs
to go and speak to them because all they
want is a deliver their lives as free
and peaceful people will the prime
minister confirm
to the people of ukraine that he will do
everything he can to end the tyranny of
putin and that he will do everything he
can to make sure that they live as a
peaceful free people
yes i certainly can confirm that mr
speaker what i can also say is that i
believe uh in
this in by making this invasion of the i
i think that uh president putin has done
uh
more than anybody else to bring his
regime uh to an end uh because i think
in the end he will pay a huge price of
what he's done and i i know that this
house want to make make it so
cold
thank you
mr speaker uh can i welcome and support
the measures um outlined by the prime
minister uh today
for years
one of the tools that he uses is through
political donations to political parties
including in this country will the prime
minister commit today to ridding
the democracy in london from uh to
reading russian money out of democracy
in this country
yes of course mr speaker
thank you very much mr speaker estonia
latvia lithuania and poland today
triggered article four of the north
atlantic treaty and i think i heard that
we are going to be joining in those
discussions but can my writer will
offend assure our nato allies in eastern
europe that we stand firmly with them
particularly the baltic states that have
significant russian populations
thank uh very i thank you very much
she's completely right and that's why
one of the first things we did was to
strengthen our presence in uh in estonia
in the way that i've described uh and uh
our canadian friends are strengthening
their presence in in latvia uh and uh we
will make sure that uh we give the the
baltic states in particular uh who who
who seceded uh from the soviet union who
became free and independent that amazing
moment give them all the security that
they deserve
debbie abrahams
thank you mr speaker there's
overwhelming evidence that russian state
actors have been involved in trying to
disrupt and destabilize western
democracies using social media platforms
such as facebook so what is the
government doing to
to ensure that this isn't used in these
events
it's because i said i think in an answer
uh a couple of days ago we've got no
evidence of of uh
disruption of uk uh elections or
electoral events as a result of uh of
russian activity but the online harms
bill
is there uh to provide such protections
mr speaker can i thank my right
honourable friend for his statement and
indeed thank the leader of her majesty's
opposition for his supportive and moving
words
um but can i also reinforce the point
made by my honourable friend for
huntington
why has it come to this past how has the
west in general and the united kingdom
in particular been so asleep at the
switch for such a long period of time
and it i commend the defense and
security review but isn't it now time to
ask what the permanent and impartial
machinery of our government does
failing to provide ministers with
consistent advice about the strategic
threats that our country faces
uh
mr speaker i think there are there are
all sorts of reasons for
uh the failure of the west to take
sufficient account of the threat of
vladimir putin since 2014
uh but the
the two biggest uh are oil and gas
nick smith
mr speaker with cyber attacks and
falsehoods russia is peddling lies today
now observers on the ground are crucial
to relay the truth now in recent weeks
the uk has withdrawn its team from the
osce special monitoring mission
because staff safety is key but can the
prime minister look again to support
international efforts like this to get
to the facts and counter russian
disinformation yeah
i thank the mmr teams uh that they're
wonderful i've i've met them and and
they do a fantastic job i'm sorry that
they've had to be with born for the for
the for the uh duty of care reasons that
he rightly uh alludes to and uh we will
keep it under constant review liam falls
the 1994 budapest memorandum saw ukraine
give up its nuclear weapons in return
for a security guarantee not only signed
by britain and the united states but by
russia
does my right honourable friend believe
that ukraine would have been invaded had
it retained its nuclear weapons and what
does it say about the value of a russian
signature on any international agreement
well it's clear that president putin uh
sets no store by international law
whatever and he's uh that is just one of
the one of the one of the legal
obligations that he has torn up esteem
you very much mr speaker we awoke this
morning to images of innocent families
carrying in tube stations we know the
putin regime's a propensity for
oppression and tourney particularly when
it comes to minorities
will the prime minister ensure that
humanitarian aid is delivered not just
in concert with other international
partners but also with third sector
organizations
yes of course so the third sector plays
an invaluable role
mr speaker i welcome the prime
minister's statement and is specifically
ruling out the threat of creeping
normalization because this house should
be under no doubt that uh putin is well
prepared he has hundreds of billions of
foreign currency reserves he has a
military that has been tested and will
the prime minister do everything he can
to convert the current intent into
frameworks that cement
our intent over time because he is
betting on the fact that it won't
my honorable friend is absolutely right
because the uh the the plan that uh the
g7 have agreed on our friends and
partners agreed on is that putin must
fail putin must not succeed in this
venture
but we've got to put in place all the
steps we need to take diplomatically
economically
and yes military in order to ensure that
that is the case and that's what we're
doing
the prime minister's right to have set
out the most stringent possible set of
sanctions against the government of
russia
um can he outline for the house what the
implications will also be for
cooperation at the international space
station
i i thank him i i thank him very much i
will have to see uh what what what
further downstream effects there are on
on collaboration of all kinds i must say
that hitherto uh i have been broadly in
favor of continuing uh artistic and
scientific uh collaboration but uh in
the current circumstances it's hard to
say see how even those uh can continue
as normal
so john hayes
speaker
the mix of uh practice and principle is
the test of democratic politics
exemplified at its best when this house
comes together in common cause
the test of leadership is the mix of
vision and will and the prime minister
is to be commended his willful clear
sighted determination
so will he now reassure the house that
he's in close touch with those countries
close to ukraine where nurse will be
frayed
and that will he send them an urgent
message that this house and this nation
will always stand alongside and behind
three nations
he's uh the right honourable gentleman
as so often is precisely right and
that's why uh together with my writable
friends of defense secretary foreign
secretary uh we've been visiting uh
poland uh romania uh the bolts uh all
the all those who who are now feeling
such deep unease at what is happening
i'll use the camera thank you mr speaker
as we speak
the softcomfloat tanker ns challenger is
birthed at sulumbo in shetland taking on
a load of crude oil for export softcom
float as the prime minister may know is
a company owned and operated by the
russian government
my constituents mr speaker are asking me
why they should be loading oil onto a
russian tanker while russian troops are
marching into the ukraine i cannot think
of any good answer to give them
so can the prime minister tell me well
anything that he has announced today
ensure that that will not happen again
in the future yeah
well i can tell him if i thank you very
much i will i will of course immediately
investigate uh what what
is happening with the softcom flot oil
tanker
but the result of the measures that the
house passed uh the other day is that we
can now target any entity any company uh
that has any relation uh with the
russian state so we have that power
symbol
speaker tyrants and megalomaniacs invade
countries because they think they can
get away with it and the way to deal
with bullies is to stand up with them so
i'm sure he will acknowledge that the
way the west responds to this aggression
will have repercussions not just for
russia and ukraine but for other bullies
like china as well and will he be
mindful of the need to show support to
russians smaller southerly neighbors
especially georgia and armenia who feel
particularly vulnerable at this time
yes i i thank him he's right because the
the read across the knock-on uh is
obvious for uh for georgia and armenia
what he what he proposes to create uh
putin is a new a new sphere of influence
a new yorker in which those countries
come behind his new anchor
thank you mr speaker as a member of this
house with ukrainian heritage
this issue particularly troubles me i'd
like to thank the prime minister for his
tone of his statement and the resolute
and swift action that is proposing in
tackling russia but the resolute and
swift support is offering to the people
of ukraine
during his speech he also highlighted
the issues of the cost of living and the
rise of uh fuel prices could he also
touch on what further action government
will take in order to address that issue
i thank him very much and i think he's
uh he's he's quite right because i think
people across the country will be
thinking about the effect on on us all
of the increase in the price of oil and
gas as a result of a war in in ukraine
uh we will continue to do everything we
can to help people to abate the cost and
to support people through uh through
councils through all the funds that
we're we're giving the the uh the
reduction in in council tax mr speaker
uh but the best thing that we can do is
ensure that people are in uh good uh
well-paying jobs and that is uh in that
we are certainly succeeding uh but the
in the in the medium
and the long term we've got to have more
self-reliance in this country on our own
energy supplies and that is that is what
this government is also uh committed to
building
jeffrey flipped to brown
mr speaker one of the most important
economic sanctions we can take against
russia is by freezing its sovereign debt
will my right honorable friend confirm
that the bill proposed on monday on
economic crime will include powers to do
so
mr speaker we're taking the most uh
powerful uh measures against uh russia
uh and russia the russian economy that
have ever uh been taken i think probably
the most popular ever taken by any
country and russia will no longer be
able to raise
any sovereign debt uh on uk markets
olivia blake
thank you mr speaker um i'd like to ask
the prime minister
what um support
we will be providing ukrainian citizens
settled in the uk who wish to reunite
with their family members still residing
in ukraine many have watched their
cities rapidly rapidly get caught up in
this conflict and are keen to know what
more we could be doing to support them
to reunite their families
mr speaker we will make sure that we
support uh ukrainian nationals who uh
need to uh leave to visit there uh to
come to this country to uh to meet their
their uh their relatives of course we'll
do that steven mike welcome
thank you mr speaker i'm proud the prime
minister in this country are leading
international support for our friends in
ukraine domestically will the prime
minister be providing more support for
organizations such as our nhs public
sector organizations and businesses that
will now be the subject of russian cyber
attacks
he's he's right to to point to this risk
uh mr speaker and i i think he it's it's
foresighted we are we're investing
massively in uh in cyber protection i
think another 2.6 billion pounds we're
putting in uh i think in the last few
years we've tackled three thousand uh
more than three thousand uh cyber
attacks it is a risk uh it's a risk that
i'm afraid we must run in the cause of
freedom
matt robert
thank you mr speaker and i'd like to
offer my wholehearted support for much
tougher sanctions against president
putin in his dreadful regime mr speaker
as the honourable gentleman from
lockerbie mentioned earlier there are
many historic ukrainian communities in
great britain and northern ireland and
indeed i would like to commend the work
of the reading ukrainian centre i would
like to ask the prime minister what
additional support can the government
give to these very valuable community
groups and centres around the country
who offer such support to families
friends relatives both in the uk and in
the ukraine
i think mr speaker perhaps the most
important thing we can do for the
ukrainian community in this country is
uh is is thank them recognize them for
everything that they've done for us in
the in the last uh decades they they've
been an amazing addition uh to the uk to
the uk economy uh to our cultural and
artistic life
thank you mr speaker
the house is united in its condemnation
but i suggest to the prime minister that
the lessons to be addressed from this
affair started with the invasion of
georgia russia's invasion georgia in
2008 and not 2014
and given you know many of us across the
house
warned about have been warning about
russia and yet the response has been
weak does the prime minister accept
that as we enter the battle for
democracy globally we have got to
understand that the sooner you step you
you square up to the playground bully
the better
and that we adequately support our hard
and soft power to do that yeah
yes he is quite right and i know that by
soft power uh he's thinking of also the
of the british council uh which can have
such uh such a wonderful beneficial
effect
across russia and i've seen it i've seen
its work across russia uh but mr speaker
he's right about standing up to the to
the playground bully uh we should have
done it uh ages ago i think the scales
have fallen from the eyes of many of our
friends and partners
thanks very much mr speaker and in an
earlier response the prime minister
suggested that this country would
welcome people who were reuniting with
family here i have a constituent who's
ukrainian but a british citizen who's
trying to bring her mother from ukraine
but being turned down because she is
over 18. her mother is on her own has no
family so naturally she's frightened so
will we see a change in the home office
to enable british citizens who are
ukrainian to bring their vulnerable
family here
yes i i thank her very much i think i
read out a helpline number in the house
uh on tuesday i don't have it again
there is a number both in both in the
abandon and in this country but if
there's if she could do me the favor and
send me the details uh we'll i'll take
them up
richard
thank you mr speaker can i commend my
old friend and his ministers for the
firm stance they're taking
none of us know where or what mr putin's
aims longer term aims are
if ukraine falls and i fear it might his
covetous eye might land on the baltic
states and other vulnerable countries
can my writer my friend reassure
nato members that if one russian boot
lands on nato soil military force will
be met by military force
yes and what is so uh encouraging mr
speaker is that the whole house
understands uh the vital importance of
that article five guarantee that we make
to every one of the thirty members of
nato
today
the prime minister quite rightly pits
this is as being a battle between the
party of war and those who support
international law there is only one
lawful government in ukraine that's the
government of president chalenski if
they are forced to move forth possibly
into exile in the short run or the
longer run will the prime minister state
very clearly that we will make sure they
can be a functional and effective
government wherever they operate from
it's a very important point that he
raises i'm grateful then that's why in
our discussions with uh president
zielinski we are seeing what we can do
to give them uh the practical uh support
that they need to continue
the city of london is a global asset
whose enduring success doesn't rest on
dirty money it rests on a commitment to
excellence
and on the adherence with the rule of
law so it's right that we now use that
as a way to show global leadership can i
encourage my right honourable friend to
sanction all of the remaining russian
banks to sanction the executives
associated with them and i notice that
many are resigning today to publish a
further list of individuals resident in
this country or otherwise to be
sanctioned and to redouble his excellent
efforts to suspend russia from swift as
the single most effective immediate step
that the west could do to put pressure
on vladimir putin
i i thank him very much i think i thank
him particularly for his important
testimonial uh to the city of london uh
whose work should not be uh should not
be sullied mr speaker by uh by
association with the ill-gotten uh
russian money but the the uh the the
program that he set out for sanctions is
exactly the right one and the one the
government is following hi kane
thank you mr speaker
returning hate for hate multiplies hates
adding deeper darkness to a knight
already devoid of stars will the prime
minister
reiterate that our quarrel is not with
the russian people it is with their
leader vladimir putin
and he has committed a very very grave
error
he is so right and i know that that is
what the house uh thinks we admire the
russian people are
our links to the russian people go back
to the time when we stood shoulder to
shoulder to fight fascism uh with the
russian people uh the russians russia's
contribution to uh culture to arts
literature is is is his answer to music
unparalleled uh it is an extraordinary
country and nothing that we do or say
should obscure that
winston churchill created the council of
europe as a bastion against fascism and
communism and since the fall of
communism russia has set great
importance by its membership as a fig
leaf of respectability every time our
conservative group has tried to get them
expelled we've been foiled by russian
gold will the prime minister now
instruct his ambassador on the council
of europe to move for the immediate
expansion of russia from the council of
europe so there is no place for
gangsters in the halls of civilized
nations
yes i think uh eloquently put mr speaker
and he's he's dead right and i think
that uh um my honourable friend for
henley made the the point uh the other
day and i certainly who's on the council
of europe i certainly agree with that
garand
mr speaker so many russians today see
the attack on ukraine as they would see
an attack of their father on their
mother because there's such intimate
family relationships between these two
groups and today thousands of russians
are protesting in cities against their
domestic law against this awful war will
he provide them with his support will he
amplify their support to help reduce the
support any support there is for this
ridiculous war and also provide
a sanction and safe haven for people
refugees including troops who may want
to re-engage uh the troops outside of
ukraine so they can re-engage so we can
win this war at home and abroad
he makes a series of extremely important
observations and yes i think it's vital
that we uh that we get the message
across uh to the whole of russia about
what is really going on they're being
lied to
day after day
and i think that is his point about uh
supporting troops who need uh
temporary exile as it were is a very
good one peter bell
thank you mr speaker i'd like to thank
the prime minister for yet again coming
to house to keep us informed and for his
leadership in this crisis
he was right to provide military aid to
ukraine
but the ukrainian ambassador did ask for
our support
in a no-fly zone today and here's a
answer earlier i think the prime
minister was keeping that option open is
that correct
yeah
i think it's pretty clear to the house
mr speaker that we're trying to keep all
our options uh open on this front uh
some of them frankly uh maybe more
practicable uh than others and i think
we have to we must also have a dose of
realism about what we can uh do on the
military front but we will keep all
things under review rachel hopkins
thank you mr deputy speaker mr speaker
um many of my many of the residents in
my constituency come from a number of
the countries on the eastern flank and
still have relatives living there
obviously like us they'll be deeply
concerned about the humanitarian impact
of the uh crisis so
what steps is the government taking to
prepare for the
humanitarian issues and with the
thousand troops on standby to help with
humanitarian assistance will they now be
deployed
i think the
uh
she weighs a very important point and uh
what we're seeing now uh tragically is
is people moving west uh out of
out of key uh columns of of traffic as
i'm sure the house knows uh we are
people already moving into uh into
southeastern poland uh
though there is going to be an influx uh
as i said to the the president of
public prime minister of poland as well
uh we're there to help
or a trop thank you mr speaker and i
thank the prime minister for his
statement today and for a strong package
of sanctions
um i want to ask him about preventing
sexual violence in conflict in november
last year we issued a strong statement
which said that the use of sexual
violence as a weapon in conflict is a
red line akin to the use of chemical
weapons
will he reaffirm that commitment today
and will he send a strong message to
russia that the international community
will not tolerate the use of sexual
violence in conflict
yes and uh i think i thank her for all
the work that she's done on that uh on
that issue uh it's something that the uh
the uk government has campaigned on for
for a long time i mean indeed uh raised
the issue very greatly in uh public
international consciousness uh i think
it uh it should be treated
as a war crime like any other and people
who perpetrate sexual violence in
conflict uh can expect uh to be tried at
that in those tribunals
ciao maura
thank you mr speaker um in seeking to
redraw the boundaries of europe through
bloodshed
putin has attacked not only the ukraine
by all of us and we stand in with
ukraine and standing for the rule of law
i welcome the sanctions that he's
announced but i was confused by his
response on russian disinformation which
he seemed to imply would be addressed by
the online safety bill that is many many
many months away russian disinformation
is organized their bots are state
sponsored what steps would he take to
address them
i think we've got a
and she raised a good point but we've
got what we're doing is a massive uh
positive uh strat coms campaign uh in in
russian in ukrainian uh
you